welcome everyone to the friday of
paideira festival amsterdam
so today is our last regular day of
talks and workshops and and everything
along those lines
and um i think we've got a really cool
program
again for you today we'll start with the
scope breakfast by addiona
i think oliana will introduce herself
at the start um during the lunch we have
another sprint preparation session
and lightning talks as well if you have
something
that you would like to talk for like
three to five minutes about
can be give me anything please sign up
it's always a lot of fun to hear what
other people are up to
this evening we have three additional
talks
we have a talk about railway oriented
programming
and a talk about making an impact with
duct tape
and how you can use artificial
intelligence to monitor
trees and forest fires and and use it
for social good
please give a warm welcome to leona
okay thanks hello everyone
uh wow we have like 84 participants it's
awesome so
let's start now my screen is shared so i
do hope that you see everything
um just a second i also got a message on
discord okay
so once again hello everyone
um i would briefly cover um
what we are going to discuss in the
workshop uh but before introducing
myself and starting i want to
point to some really important stuff um
at
the github repo so if you just join if
you just clone it and want to
follow along um maybe it will be not
possible because you need
to download at least eight gigabytes of
data
and the weight from release pages uh
also what i notice
if you're from lean if you're working on
linux
or a mac you can follow along if you're
on windows and don't use in vsl
uh windows subsystem of linux
then we need to do some changes
okay so let me
and i tried to give all instruction uh
as neat as possible
in the uh readme file
just make sure make sure that you follow
the steps
okay so let's start
yeah the title of this workshop is
human-like visual search application of
small data sounds cool so let's see what
it will be
so the workshop materials this is a link
to github repo or you can pick it up
from discord channel
read read me file and install everything
from environment jumbo okay so this is
our workshop structure
so the first will be brief introduction
who am i why i'm here to talk to you
then we'll discover briefly the building
blocks of cmu's mask air cnm
uh then we'll discuss abs mask air cnn
single deployment with fast api
and what is the link to this material
the link is in a github repo and as well
in discord channel
this is what i see
oh okay
then known limitation and possible
improvements
okay so introductions first about me who
am i
my name is elona galeva currently i work
in as a principal data solutions
engineer at linkit with emphasis on
predictionizing machine learning
and as i was joking during the day i
have a full-time job during the night i
work for five ladies but it's just a
joke
so and i'm one of two co-organizers of
pi ladies amsterdam
and i would briefly tell you about what
is this
so pilot is amsterdam it's a local
chapter of a global non-profit pilot is
and last november our chapter was
officially recognized by python software
foundation so we are really proud about
it
and each chapter has its own freedom
what to do
and with only one concern that at least
95 percent
of the activities should be dedicated to
python of course
so um what we do
as a pilot is amsterdam uh we are doing
coding workshops
on a monthly basis and later we even had
a boot camp so how it looks like
so before the covet situation it was
looks like this
this is the situation after the workshop
uh we even have naomi the former chair
of python software foundation
the joint by coincidence one of our
workshops
um yeah like happy people
i hope you see those pictures this is
how the settings looks like
when you do the cutting part and after
february so this was actually the last
offline workshop and this is the
how we decided to continue further with
online workshops
okay so feel free to contact me via
linkedin
or any other channel um i think
as i mentioned before we have this
building blocks
so and between these blocks we can take
some time for q a
and then as well as you know after this
session
uh you will have a aftercare time when
you ask all your questions on discord
and i will be happy to answer it here
so let me briefly check after the
introduction let me briefly check the q
a
and then we'll follow okay um
i see the question from thomas hanke i'm
trying to run the repo i missed the end
file with the relative path could you
please share a copy
let me briefly check
one second actually it should be in the
root folder
and oh okay you get ignored
yes my git ignore yeah
uh shooter what the best option should i
push it right okay i think
i can just brief really really fast push
it
yeah okay da da sorry my bets it goes
automatically
yep
yes
and for those who wants to
have some time and get a cup of coffee
you have a time for it
for now at least for two minutes i think
okay one second
i'm merging it with master right now
yes so please refresh the repo and you
will get access to it
yes now it's here okay uh
anything else what i see yeah the link
to material okay
so we covered i think we're ready to go
for the next one okay so
before let's briefly recap
what is common computer vision tasks
so i think i assume a lot of you have
seen this picture before
so when we're talking about computer
vision we are talking mostly about
classification
object detection semantic segmentation
or instance segmentation or even more
so if we are talking about
classification
is briefly we are looking at the picture
and we're saying if
there is an object if it's present or
not or it's like
that's it's i think the basic thing the
object detection
takes the next step forward an object
detection say to us
first check if the object is on the
picture
and then if we can locate where this
object
is on the picture so basically we are
talking about the
um given we call them bowden boxes it's
just uh
it's a great coordinates where an object
is located
so yeah sounds not so complicated for
now then we have the segmentation
what is segmentation when we're talking
about segmentation
it's pixel-wise classification so in
this case
we should say that each pixel from this
balloon
is belongs here and this pixel doesn't
belong to
these balloons but the semantic
segmentation is a little bit limited
because it
treats all these objects
as one thing and now we finally
went to the instant segmentation and
it's really interesting concept
so you don't only have the pixel
vise classification and you know that
each pixel belongs to each object you
know
exactly to which object this pixel
belongs
so now you see that we have this as i'll
say like bound in boxes where the
balloons are located we can count these
balloons
and we know that all these balloons are
separate instances
so sound really really cool right
so why i'm talking about this because
original idea of the app of the virtual
search
will be using the instance segmentation
although we need to mention
the cmu's network as well so the first
time when it came across the cmu's
network
um was oh by the way it was um at the
joint events of pi data amsterdam and
panelists amsterdam
so we have nlp talks and so far as i
remember
uh the last person uh was presented uh
it was from text kernel and this person
actually present
the thing how they use cmu's network to
find the similarities
um in job vacancies in different
languages
so if we are talking about cms neural
networks
for computer vision so we have let's say
two pictures two images that we want to
compare
and we put these images let's say
through the convolutional neural network
then we get let's say two big weak
vectors and we just compare
the distance between these vectors and
let's say
okay is it looks like similar or not
why do we need this um if we want to
search for something
and if we are trying to search something
with a picture and we try to find
another picture it's really nice to
understand whether these pictures are
similar
or not and then because
we the model that we are going to use
it's
cmes it uses cmu's neural network
it uses instant segmentation and on top
of it
it use one-shot instant segmentation so
what is
one shot segmentation there is a cool
concept
that is called meta learning
and if we look at it so we can talk
about
zero shot one shot or few shots learning
in this case we are working with cms
architecture again
in the first case with the zero shot
what we actually give we give not an
image but we give
text text that describes something
and we have an image and we compare
these two branches
like image and text to find whether it's
belongs to or not if we're talking about
one shot so
actually we're trying to have one
picture
and then compare it to with another
picture
and if we have the few shot then we know
that
at least our model have seen at least
depends on the number of
pictures we define the number of shots
and we say whether it's
one shot too short three shell depends
on the number of the pictures
so this is really really brief brief
recap so
yeah we will be talking about cme's
mask air cnn so this is the neural
network that was originally built
um on resnet then we have on top of
resnet we have
all these layers that do its job and we
have mask rcnn
and then the cmes um
the same as architecture was added to
that to perform the tasks
so okay let's
go further so once again if you
clone the repo if you just clone the
repo it will take
some time for you because you need to
download at least eight gigabytes of
data it will be done you can start
downloading them
by the way because it's done by script
uh
also if you're doing it on linux or mac
it will work
if you're going to do it on pure windows
um there is an issue the source code of
the libraries has some hardcoded path
and this hard coded path are linux
oriented so this is the issue with
windows
um so if you have windows sorry
only one option first to use it as i use
it right now so
uh i run in this workshop on windows 10
but
on uh actually on ubuntu on linux on vsl
so for windows people i think we can go
back to it later because i can
rearrange the workshop for windows but
we need to rewrite a lot of
source codes of these two models to get
rid of it
okay so let's start and cover the
building blocks of mask
simi's or cnn so we came to this
inevitable step to download
all required libraries um this is let's
say
the most tedious part but we need to
have it
um i should say that's not the best
practice as well to use
to take the environment variables here
so we can discuss later how it can be
improved
but now before diving in i have one task
for all of you
so my repo currently is missing one
really mission critical folder so think
about it
which folder is missing or what should
be
placed in this folder and let's get back
to it at the end of our workshop
i'm really curious to see all your
replies what kind of folder
with what kind of i don't know pieces of
code or maybe something else is missing
here
so okay first make sure that you're in a
content environment
when you work on vsl you need to check
it in some places just
let me have a sanity check
this way yes so this is
we are here i have conda and we are here
okay
so let me run first
to download all the libraries
and actually what's happening there uh
first we read
we're using dot and that's the file that
was missing
my bad sorry because usually you don't
share such information on github refers
so then you download basic libraries
um and then the rest of it this are the
source code
this one this is the source code for
mask air cnn and this is the source code
for
the cms mask rcnn and as well since pass
appends trust me it's not the best
practice to do
so we can discuss how it can be improved
later
okay so now we the model um we
the model we are going to use uh it's
already pre-trained
um why because it's really really heavy
so now i have two configurations for
this model
one configuration is approximately like
uh it takes one week to train on
four uh gpus and if you try to train the
small config
although it's transfer learning so
you're not
training it's from scratch um
it requires approximately like uh four
or five days
so that's why in this workshop we are
going to use this pre-trained models
and i know that not everybody has
an access to gpu on the laptops
um that's why this model can run on cpu
i mean the predictions the inference
part can run on cpu
and actually it uses still
let's say all types of libraries so it
still uses tensorflow 1.13
and it was the time when if you want to
run tensorflow and gpu
and tensorflow and cpu you need to
install two complete different
um let's packages for tensorflow
it seems to me that only after 1.16 they
now merge it into one
so in this case even this code says it
let's say it's run on gpu
uh it runs on cpu as well so it's
it's okay to know so first i just loaded
all the libraries
and then before diving to the model
let's briefly recap
what is ms coco so this model was
originally trained on the ms coco data
set
and actually it's a large scale object
dictation segmentation captioning data
set
um it has a lot of annotations a lot of
images
so yeah the decision to train this model
in this particular data set i think was
uh actually because of all the
annotations that were available for it
um yeah but we'll see and
for this particular use case for the
mask rc for cmu's masker cnn
this uh data set was processed in a very
specific way
and actually let me first run this cell
yes that's they define one-shot classes
so we have for a for a data set we have
80 categories for mass cocoa 80
categories and based on this formula
they actually choose some categories for
one shot classes
to perform one-shot instant segmentation
later
okay so this is our data set as i
mentioned and as i said before
we need to download it so the scripts
that is
in data in in data utilities folder
um let you to download a train and
validation
sorry not train validation and test set
so it will that's what i mentioned it
was approximately eight gigabytes that
will take eight gigabytes of space
in the future if you want to play with
this model further i advise you
um i have a link to the original wrapper
with a source code
so go and download the original
the training sets but it will take
approximately like
30 gigabytes of space but for the
purpose of this workshop we're
downloading only
uh eight now i have the data set
downloaded on my local machine
so in this case i just run some
preparations
to to load the subset of it
in this case validation to prepare to
build some indices to know where to look
for
and to activate one shot classes
okay so now let's take a look at the
model
so this is the original model that was
uh used as a base this is a musk air cnn
model
and actually what this model does i want
to briefly cover its components
so we have backbone uh think of a
backbone as a feature extractor
and this backbone uh it can be resonant
at 50 or is net
101. so this is our feature extractored
so we have different layers the first
layers extract the
low level features such as ages corners
think rates and then it goes to the
more high level features like person sky
so after that when we have our features
instructed we pre-process them as well
with feature pyramid network and what's
interesting with this model it has
actually two
that's why it works and performs better
so
it's actually like um um
it improves uh the whole feature
extraction process as well
and then we are going to the hotspot so
what's happening here
here we have airpn airbn stands for
region proposal network
so this is really lightweight neural
network what it's actually doing so
it scans the whole image in a sliding
window fashion and finds uh all areas
that
contain object of our interest and
what we do um we perform like the scan
or we call them anchors so actually
each picture has can has a lot of this
anchors
more like than 200k anchors whatever
different on the size of the images and
what we are doing
and yeah if you do it on gpu it's pretty
fast if you're doing a cpu it's
uh slower but this what you get from it
and then we oh i forgot to mention that
when you working with rpn
what we have here so we get uh the
anchor class and usually it
works it has two classes it has a class
that say okay this is object
is on background and this is the object
in the foreground
and it creates the bounding boxes and
try to say okay
try to refine this bound in boxes at the
end to say so
there is like the high probability that
something is in it
let's refine it to this bounding boxes
and then
only after that we go through the um
roi high classifier we pick up only
regions of interest
and then we process it further
um we do some pooling because for
classifiers it's really hard to
understand if all inputs is not
very well sized so um
and then uh let's say the last step for
us
with this model uh this is to create the
segmentation mask
and this is really uh oh sorry
and this is really let's say tedious uh
tedious task to create them
so yeah this is uh the the back bonus
uh sorry this is the mask rcnn model
and now let's take a look at the
architecture of sami's mask air cnn
and as i mentioned before they're really
heavy models so
yeah this is masker cnn
if you see the difference between these
two models this is
actually the cme's backbone that was
added here
so it looks almost like the same the
heads parts
here we have backbone with resnet and
here we have cme's backbone so
in this case we have one image
or batch of images as an input and we
get some
um predictions and masks at the end
and with cmes we have a reference image
an
image we do feature extraction and
feature
matching and if there is a match then we
proceed further
with hats so i think it's enough of
theory
um it was too much so for this
option we can talk about different
configurations i mentioned before so we
have small configuration
and we have a large configuration
the difference in the way how they were
trained
but for both of them we have pre-trained
weights
that's why i say so if you want to play
along with inference don't forget to
download
them from release and if you want to
train this model further
as well so we have the small
configuration and large one
let me start
it's okay it's done and then let's pick
model size
okay let's start with a small one for
now
okay i just run the configuration
so now it says if we say config display
remember that
here for the small evaluation config we
say okay this is gpu
images per gpu the basic information
and here when we asked to display the
config we see the backbone resonant 50
and the rest of the parameters what i
was
worth mentioning um that the whole
approach
to train this model was
we know that resnet usually trades on
imagenet
dataset so that people who wrote this
paper
and who proposed this model they
actually go through
imagenet datasets and they remove the
categories
that um that ms coke already has
in order to not to have let's say the
same categories twice
so this we download the config of our
model then it just
picks the checkpoint
to download weights and that's what i
mentioned yeah this hardcoded path
and you see that it's applicable for
linux or mac but not applicable for
basic windows okay so
now um the first part was it's a really
brief introduction about what the model
does what the
peculiarities how it performs
and your home assignment will be to
investigate the regional article
the source codes and lib folder and
think over what can be improved and
optimized for better performance
um what i also forgot to mention
about this one um yeah
really important part um about this
so when we do this matching remember so
we have features and when we do this
matching
let's say we just measure the distance
between them and if it's
okay we pass it further to airplane
and and if it's not then
sometimes we're stopping okay so this is
that for that part
it was really brief i think now we have
uh
let's say one two four minutes uh if you
have any questions regarding this part
and then we uh move further for the
deployment
okay i'm just reading uh in the meantime
yeah
the zoom webinar chart
okay
so now i don't see anything incoming
so i can assume that we can move forward
a question just yeah siamese network is
that both networks are identical right
it's a question by dennis buckhouse yeah
just second yeah so video simulator boss
network's identical right
yeah they're different as well if we go
in depth into the cms architecture there
is some stuff that's called
um it's not mirrored series network i
don't yeah so the idea
yeah let's say there should be identical
and
but there are different configuration of
it as well so
um yeah in this case we
we assume in this
that they are identical in this case
yeah
okay
okay um
so i think we can go further
uh if there are no questions or oh no i
see something popping up
uh okay
so i ran content creative environment
yaml but after resolving conflicts the
up environment doesn't show up
on the environment least uh good
question
um first of all it can be another if you
do
conda and flist i'm wondering what kind
of uh
environment you get maybe just get
another name
uh if not uh
i think we need to check the actually
the configuration of conda
i don't know what you're using using
bashish or what kind of terminal do you
use
uh i remember that thomas mentioned that
he works on mac so as you may visit or
bash
um
version mac okay frankly speaking i
don't remember from my head
all the comments to configure conda
maybe this is good for the um yeah to
really dive into
yeah yeah i think this great one okay if
thomas if it's okay then
i think we can move forward for this uh
the
yeah then the question from grima so why
keep two networks
hmm it's really good question so
actually it's not
two networks it's one network
uh i will go back for a second it's
really good question thank you
so in this case what we have we have
image
then we constructed features we
extracted pictures from this image
and then we continue further with this
in case we see a mes we want to
compare to why we're doing this
if we want in the future use masks air
cnn
we cannot just uh apply any and
retrain it on a new data set it's not
possible just
yeah add any images without any
pre-processing without
any extra annotation masks
and it's really tedious tasks actually
i think personally that one-shot
learning or zero shot or
fuchsia learning tried to solve this
problem we call this small data
because okay now you have this large
data set but what if you want to
fine-tune your network for particular
use case and then
you need even although you're using
transfer learning
uh you take the part of mask rcnn you
remove the last layer the classifier or
some layers it depends on how um how
deep
uh you want to have uh not not deep
sorry
um so in the transfer learning um
you still need a lot of images that's
what i'm trying to say
uh if you're using cmes um same is
network
uh it try for you it try for you to
reduce this overhead and it's saying so
what we're trying to do um we tr based
on
only some of the images so not one
hundreds of thousands of millions
based on two three five six images
when the model sees this particular
object once
we give a task to this model to find
this object on the rest of the images
so that's i think
the the light version of explanation
why to keep two um personally what i
noticed
i can say that i'm a little bit biased
towards maybe
engineering part so for me this model
the cms mask air cnn model
is really computationally
expensive and regarding inference is as
well really computationally ex
expensive so i'd rather use first
separate cmu's maskers cms neural
network
let's say like the first model that will
filter stuff from you say okay if there
is i have two in common images
if they're match then push them
downstream to protest by another
lightweight neural network uh to
classify them further or do the magic
and um in this case it's one model
that's why it runs although trained it
still runs
really really slow um yeah but that's
something that it's not possible to
solve by one neural network and
we try to use different or combine them
as a
let's say combo to get the best results
so i think now i can continue if there
are any
let's say questions about this part uh
please talk to me
after uh i will be there with you in the
discord channel
and we can discuss actually do we need
this or not is it the best approach or
not but
for now for this particular task um this
is the article from
2019 um i checked also the
latest articles research papers from
2020
we have um if i'm not mistaken
the name um of the facebook algorithm is
detectron
so it's they also advertise it as
algorithm they can do everything
and classification object segmentation
semantic segmentation
so a lot of stuff in one i didn't tried
it yet so i don't know
what to expect from it so let's see
okay so now we
let's move to the second part and
idea was to create a visual search up
so how i envisioned this search app
imagine i have an image and based on
this image
i want to find the similar one that's
why we're saying like visual search
so and this can be done only by using
cmes neural network in this case so
actually
we will transform images or videos
depends on what we want to do
and then compare them and if there is
let's say
if there is a match then we say okay
maybe
this picture looks like this uh
in case with uh
if you want to get something more out of
it not just say okay
this two images are identical or looks
like or look similar but if you want to
go
for a next step and identify
what exactly located on this image
as a use case think over e-commerce for
example
yeah recommendation system uh based on
or um it can be i don't know
any like um
how we call it web yeah web shops so you
say okay
i'm looking for this particular article
and
i got the recommendation of the articles
that looks like this
okay maybe in this case the cmes neural
network will do its job
but if we want to have something more if
we want to get
not just okay it looks similar but i
know
that the thing that you're looking for
this image we have
at this image as well where particularly
in this image we have it
what are the boundaries of it and
um even to identify each
let's say each items it's completely
different story
and for now we don't have this unique
engine
that do it so that's why we we're trying
let's say to prototype something
and for this um i decided to use the
cmu's mask rcnn
although it's slow for now because it
can give us at least a possibility to
look into the future so
when we are talking about deployment um
what i want to emphasize so the model
that we have
it's not the end product right so this
model
lives in the world and it's surrounded
by a lot of things and it should
interact with a lot of pieces
so when i thinking about the
machine learning models i always think
in them in the case of the pipeline
so we always have some data in
we need to understand that the data are
correct so in our case if it's a video
stream or
just images we need to be sure that it's
images and or something else
and that we pre-process this images we
resize them
reshape them and make them digestible
for the model
then we train the model then we spend a
lot on model tuning and there are a lot
of
useful tools on the market available for
it and then we
analyze the model we validate it and
only after that we say okay
maybe now it's time to try to deploy
this model first
uh to the dev uh and then further to the
stage and maybe to production
in the future and also we need to find a
way how to collect the feedback
so in this case if we are talking about
our model um and if we want to build
this visual search thing
so we need to think first okay so we
will have
incoming images or videos then we need
to process this images we have already
our pre-trained model
so now we're using two configurations
small and big one
okay what's the next step
and here is a thing i just decided to
show this uh table this is cpu we see
gpu deployment
uh this is the question that i always uh
asked so what should we do
um should we use this or this as i
mentioned if the model is really heavy
maybe we can use the gpu but then the
question is
what are the cost of using it and if
we're just doing some
funds fun app for yourself it will be
really really costly
so what's to do cpu or gpu
that's hard questions that you always
ask
this is just comparison of throughput
uh image per second from this side we
have image per second
from this side we have different uh
biggest models
and the frameworks and then we have
comparison the blue thing
it's a cpu this is the blue one you see
the performance of it
and red one this is when we use three
gpu
and as i mentioned before this model was
trained on
four on four cpus
so let's check what's the idea of visual
search how it looks like
first we will initialize our model
in inference mode and load checkpoints
to use it so it can take some time
for initialization okay so let's say
we're loading checkpoints and we're
starting from epoch 160.
and then we say we have different
categories that we can change
and we have our target image this is the
smallest
image and then we have our another image
in this case target image is
preprocessed and it has it contains
masks it contains bounding boxes and all
annotations
and in case with the image that we're
trying to compare to
it's it has only
it has only basic annotations but it
doesn't have masks anything
so the idea is with this target small
target image
to see how we can what we can extract
from this
big image so let me run this just to
show you what will be there
yeah it can take some time as i
mentioned let's take a look at the
results
yeah so you see that's not the best one
so the target
image is really small uh even for me
it's hard to identify it looks like it's
a
moo or a birds and it's actually try to
identify the birds in the cage
and say okay i'm pretty sure that this
is something
bird birdish like and then somehow it
picks up
their um yeah the screen and the person
as well
something that looks like maybe a bird
on the background
um yeah so still you see without all
this
uh fine tuning and this is the let's say
the
paper um
with a lot of efforts and still you see
this
still models performs really really
strange
okay here we have the pigeon as a
reference
and although we have found the pigeon
this picture doesn't contain pigeon but
it
it picks up the bird so it's a good one
uh
it says okay i almost almost 100
sure that that's what i'm looking for
the shape look like this so it's a bird
and then it still picks up their stuff
the biggest issue with visual search in
real life
um if you want to perform it um
normally you do it in really let's say
cluttered settings
because if you look back at the
let's say basic data sets you have
something
on the foreground really big one almost
always in the center
and then you say okay my model performs
great it identifies but in real life
case you have a lot of things on the
background
so yeah and this is the really hard so
the idea
of our app let's say of our application
will be
that we have we give it just a random
image
and we say compare it with a target
and if you see the similarity map
on my image all these objects identify
these objects at the separate objects
draw the bounding box and apply the mask
the segmentation mask this is the
original idea
okay so now let's start building our
first api uh
with fast api uh regarding deployment i
also want to
note i'm talking now about single
deployments what do you mean by that
this is the first time we deploy only
one model
um that's it it can be other
all other options will not cover it here
uh there are a lot of pros and cons
um which framework to choose to deploy
the models how to do it
it depends on the models it depends on
the incoming data it's a lot of moving
pieces in it
so um usually if you
look at the look at the internet there
are different tutorials that are talking
about like
uh yeah build a flask up only two lines
of code and you're ready to go
unfortunately in real life
uh with a flask app it doesn't work this
way
because it even when you do some stuff
with
let's say flask and if you're not using
the servers
um yeah uh or you can go with a
tensorflow serving if you have like
tensorflow
compatible models or convert your models
to tensorflow compatible format
um you have different cloud
options of deploying your model we have
the sagemaker
that can do a lot of stuff for us we
have
automl um and then we have as well such
things like a seldom
if you're working with kubernetes that
there are possibility to deploy model
scale descale really fast but for the
sake of this
workshop we'll be doing some magic with
first api
i heard that actually there was a
session
on monday we're getting fast api so i'm
really looking forward to
re-watching the record records of this
video
and why fast api it looks really neat it
looks really nice so
yeah let's start and i will show you
actually why the first api
okay so for now
let me open the mendel pi
first we briefly cover the
the code and then to see what the
what it can give us so um
once again it's not a production level
thing in this case the cod is not
optimized it has
a lot of hard-coded stuff uh and usually
when you create
an ipi uh you create the structure
because you want to separate concerns
you don't want to have one file that do
everything for you in our case we're
using two files
uh it's main dot pi file that will run
our
fast api up and uh as well we're using
another it calls
settings settings.pi
so usually when you
when you configure your api yeah you
have some
variables or secrets that you want to
keep you don't want to expose them to
people
there are different ways how you can do
it so in this case
i need a path to up test data to the
coke data set
to the mask rcnn model path this is
because of all hard-coded dependencies
in the source code
and the model directory when we will uh
when we have
all logs for our model directory uh
maybe i'm jumping sorry if i jump too
fast between the components of something
unclear
please ask or let's discuss it after and
the discord
so if we are talking about prototyping
something
uh we want to have let's say something
that do his job and if we're talking
about an
app uh so yeah we can always ask
somebody or
build the simple front-end for us but
before doing this we need to understand
how we can
input data and output data from it so in
this case if we want to do this we want
to say okay
i want to upload my image
and then based on the image i want to
get the results
so to get something that looks like this
so
i upload the image it compare with the
target image
and it gives me back something and
usually
what we are doing we want
found some way how we want to
communicate with our model
and we need to find a way how we can
send data to our model and how we can
get back get data back from our model so
in this case that's why we're building
this api
so let's briefly check what is here so
once again we load in the basic
libraries
then we load the fast api related
libraries
with some extensions with the
possibility to
upload files and as well
what i really love in this case so under
hood it uses pydentic
and actually it allows you to validate
your data so remember garbage in garbage
out in this case it doesn't allow a lot
of garbage to come in
when doing this all these calls then we
invert
the stuff to get the environment up and
running
and this once again this terrible hack
to make it running because of all the
hardcoded dependencies in the in the
source code of both libraries
and here what we're doing we actually
define our request body
so um we have we can have different
options before sending images whatever i
wanted to try to send something
like to pick up a category number so uh
let's say the first step
um i know that for now if we are working
with the mass coco data set
we index all images and we know that
uh some of the images belongs to
different categories so
the first call that everyone tried to do
i said what if
i can send the number of the category
and let the model
randomly pick up target image image
compare them and return results if there
was some findings
uh there was some something similar and
for this i define just the incoming
request this is our
request body and i say it should be
number because in our case category it's
a number it's an integer
and then we can as well define all
for all other requests uh the format and
as well we can define the format here so
it's
it it works like a error catching uh
it's
double checking your input and output
then this class was defined just to
to decode uh the
uh and the arrays to the json formats
and then what we have here we have the
our small evaluation config
we have large evaluation config files so
we can
work with two types of the models in
inference mode and then
the code for now we need to load model
i want to point out one thing what i
really
often see in the code so the people try
to
load the model not in the very beginning
but they tried to load model with each
request
and i want to point out that it's highly
inefficient
because imagine is every time you send a
request you load your model again
and if you have a big model and if it
takes a lot of time
then yeah then what you get
um i just saw the answer i'm getting
here config app test data is missing has
no default when running
um and this is the question from
sebastian
uh to get rid of this thing uh you need
to
first make sure that you have dot n file
uh because i edit it in the morning
to the wrapper uh so you need to make
sure that
this um dot end file in place and if you
want to run this
main.pi file you need to run it from the
workshop root folder so we'll
come to this part that's why it's saying
it's missing because it's
try it's called the settings and
settings
reading uh our environment for variables
from dot
nth and if you don't had them in place
that's why it complains that it's
impossible to run it
okay let's let me get back
okay so
for this now we are loading model so i
stopped the place for this
loading model so we can pick up a small
or big size
uh it gives a configuration and use a
checkpoint
to download the weights then we
initialize our model
and we we need as well to have a graph
if we don't use the graph here then we
will
got a really nasty error especially
from the oldest version of tensorflow
because each time it will try to
recreate the graph it's really
computationally
expensive as well so we load model
in our model return the model and graph
to us okay sebastian say let's edit
environment
file things yeah it's important normally
uh when you will be working it will be
up to you to decide
uh how you or your company manages
the secrets manages all environment
variables
i usually have the set of different yaml
files or
dot n files where you put all necessary
environmental variables and the rest of
it
thing cover um if you want to deploy an
app now we're doing the really really
basic version of it
so we actually what we're doing we say
okay spin up the load the model
uh send a number or upload an image sent
an image there
pre-process it send it there and get
back some uh
reply from the model uh in json format
definitely
um and then
okay i see as well the one question
uh one person raised the hand
okay
two person raised hands okay
i think if you raise the hands maybe if
you want to stop me okay let me know
it will be really helpful if you send it
as a question
i think maybe then i can understand kind
of how
how can i help you so please these two
people who raise the
the hands please uh send the questions
or if you want uh if it can wait so we
can discuss it later
uh in the after care session at discord
it's up to you
okay
so as i mentioned before we load in our
model
then we prepare in our data set um
to index it once again maybe we can do
all
the preparations before it shouldn't be
in one app but for the sake of this demo
uh we're doing this uh then we have
need to some prepare reshaping the image
and then we
initialize our first api actually the
whole concept of the festa api really
looks like looks similar to flask so if
you have experience with flask before
it's really easy to switch
so we initialize the up in the beginning
we say the model is none
then we replace it and we load our model
we load our graph
uh just for here i added the basic
uh yeah this argument just to pick up
which size of the model we want to
load then we prepare data sets okay and
then we define
so it looks once again we use decorators
it looks like
the flask what's the difference
here we can immediately define the
format what you want to do you want to
get
or you want to pass something or you
won't put or delete
so we say up gets and then we'll see how
it works
in a second and then you can define the
rest
in this case it's a post method
what this pause method is doing it's
saying i want to pick up the category
in the range from 1 to 80
and based on this category i will
randomly
pick up and let's say the big image that
doesn't have
any masks or annotations
and then i want to pick up the target
image like the small
image that has masks all
annotations attached to it and then i
will
ask the model to check these two images
and return back to me the results and
say
to me in the json format okay so what we
get from it we want to see
all regions of interest we want to see
all
uh the masks there are there are a lot
of masks
then we want to see the class adis and
the scores that we get
and we return the json results and then
as well
uh this is the really simple one just
like a sanity check to see what's
happening there
and then we have let's say we're trying
to predict the image
so actually what we do we upload a file
we read this we upload this file we read
this file
we pre-process it we resize it based on
the
necessities we remember we add only one
image it's the big one and we'll compare
it with the target
one and as well we run the predictions
normally on all fast api tutorials you
don't need to
use if name main you don't need to use
this part
and you don't need to import
the unicorn on top what you can do
you can just use a command uvcorn
app app reload and it will spin up a
unicorn server for you
but for now i do this only in the sake
of
let's say the possibility to choose the
size of the model
okay so for now let's say
we want to run it and we want to have
the
small one and while we will be running
this file
i want to show you um what's
the let's say the edit value of fast api
so let me run it
python and as i mentioned because we are
choosing the
size i just added basic
use k here so around two small large
so let's first try to work with a small
one
okay i didn't
um decided to close all warnings just to
see what's happening
okay we loaded the model uh we
pre-processed our data set we
index it and now we can open our up
okay let me
let me put it here and i will make it
um it's still i think it's still really
small
okay so what we
have here we have our basic get results
we say okay go here to go to the route
and
if it's okay if the success send us this
message
so we send this message and now
only from the next one how to test the
post
usually you will be using postman or
just curl it
it depends on your preferences but the
first api
comes with a really good thing uh it
collaborates really easily with swagger
so if i want to test the apis
in this case i just need to add docs
voila what we see here so this is
our visual search app
and then we get actually our methods
that are available so we have gets this
is our read route
our pi data amsterdam festival rules
message
and then this our two post methods that
we described
one is predict image by category and
another one
is just predict image so first
option we send the category and let's
try it
i think we can even make it a little bit
bigger like this
to make it more visible so let's check
first category
so first what you see you see
example value schema let's get back to
it
so remember our schema so this is that's
inherited from fidentic and you say we
can define the class of our body the
server-based model and define that
it should be a number and it should be
an integer
okay let's check it
so if i say try it out so now we see the
schema
it's already prepared it for us to send
a request let's say the category 15
and then say execute
okay so what we get
so that was our curl we are sending
the request to a mono um
pretty big category and this is response
body
so this file is really really huge if i
scroll it down because what it returns
for now for the
sake of this demo we ask him to return
to show
the region of interest and we ask to
return the mosques
and actually there is something an
interest in this picture it gives us
fall
it gives us true and if there is nothing
it gives a false
so there are a lot of masks here then we
have
at the end of it uh if i manage to
scroll down if not
i will go for the okay
yeah it's still so it looks like the
category that we picked
that the target image and the original
image doesn't have
a lot of in similarity oh you see some
true popping up and the masks
okay so that's what we have
and then what if i i remember that i
have
uh the category numbers for the ms coco
data set is from
1 to 80 and what if i want to put some
i don't know some strange stuff here so
what if i put like
i don't know something like this let's
try to send
okay and it says unprocessable entity
good
what if i sent a number
like one hundred
i get okay and the message uh i say so
if category not in range
return the message please indicate a
number in the range from 1 to 80.
definitely you will not doing this in
production but just for the sake of the
demo to see
how we can play with the first api and
how we can play with swagger we are
doing this
okay so we try this part
okay now the most interesting thing what
if we try to predict the image
so we are taking the big image
from the test set this image was not
seen by the model before
so we are taking this one and then we
say
randomly initialize the target image
and compare them and return the results
to me
so in this case because here with fast
api
allows us to define uh to use
op to define that the classes that we're
using so we use an upload file
file uh it just allows
us to upload the image uh so what do we
need
it will be a string and binary formats
let's try it out
let's choose file okay
let's check data coco
and it's test yeah
what image to pick up any ideas
i don't know something
maybe something like this let's try
execute
remember that all those predictions are
running currently on the
cpu
so we send the image
it was pre-processed resized then it was
fit sent to the model and
compared with the target and this is
actually
the results that we get from it our
regions of interest
the masks and the rest so this is really
really
basic thing that you can do there are
much more
that you can do with fast api as i
mentioned before
starting from define your input schema
you can use queries here you can use a
lot
um normally it depends on the model
uh how you expect from the model to
return predictions do you want to do it
in batch size
this mod this particular model is
optimized for batch
inference as well so
it can accept not only the one image it
can accept the list of images and can
accept the list of target images
so we can even send more
then normally when you do this you want
definitely to work with some database to
save indexes or to save some
necessary result there so there are much
more
that can be here with a fast api
highly recommend to go and investigate
further uh for now i think i want to
briefly also try
another model so it was the small one
let's just
really really briefly check the
the big one
large
okay so it's loading checkpoints uh it's
starting
and loads into memory lots annotation to
memory
yes loading checkpoints
great let's start
good once again when we started we are
getting to this particular
site and then if we go to dogs
we're here again so let's just try image
trade out choose file anything we want
on a server board for example
the large config and this much heavier
that's why the predictions take much
more time
and right now my pc is trying doing its
best
to run it okay
so we get the return okay
finish the process so let's get back to
slides
um and here in the slides
let's try for now to have
the the large model
just to see what's happening there
okay now we have the large config
now we select checkpoints
and then we need to load the model
the biggest config for the model oh
really interesting go to equal
okay oh yes we need to arrange the
shapes
because the shapes in this case we need
to preprocess the data
okay i got what's happened
okay because the shapes doesn't match
okay then this will we need to change
that then
and if i go back yeah dimension [ __ ]
is not equal
yeah for the smallest one and it takes a
big one
okay so we can refresh it or
i think taking take on the time uh
i think we can do go to the next steps
for now
and then get back to check
so the home assignment in this case
shares some ideas how to improve our mpi
so hints think about security how we can
make a securable
how we can use cash uh how we can split
it up for routers now we have one big
file
it's not the best way to have and what
kind of validation schema we can add
to spot all issues so that's
really it for the home assignment and
then
i think we can go for the next part so
yeah the no limitations and possible
improvements of the model
um so it's really nice idea to build
such kind of app around our api
but still we see that it's really
computationally expensive really one
and what we noticed as well that if we
have the cluttered scenes so a lot of
objects
then our model uh really still performs
let's say not really good for some
categories to do
its job really good um in the article
you can find the confusion mattresses
and it's actually
showing um how the model
performs it also gives the hints of some
overfitting
at least for training data then
in our case i mentioned we have the
false positives that biased
toward the most frequent training
categories and the training sets and you
can get assume what kind of this
categories are because almost a lot of
pictures have people on it
or a lot of pictures have some round
shaped objects in it
so our model that was never seen like
don't have any ground truth and never
seen
like this categories before but uh have
seen this a lot of times
uh while concentrating on detecting
other objects and classifying other
objects
so it still picks it up and also what we
noticed that
if we are trying to do predictions in
novel categories
then uh actually the yeah the
performance of models really dropped
dropped this is like the case with this
pigeon when you ask
uh to show the pigeon and uh it
identifies the birds really good but it
also picks up
the rest of the clutter are sometimes to
do with weird things
uh for example if you want to identify a
bus and it founds a buff and then try to
identify
the stop lights of the bus so there's
still
a large room for improvement so the
possible improvements
um yeah we can try to retrain this
and change the architecture a little bit
in a more lightweighted manner
the codebase definitely requires a lot
of refactoring
and what i mean by that i mean the
source base for both libraries because
it has a lot of hard-coded
um yeah then if you want to use this
because i just
use this let's say the model i i
generate a model in inference mode and
immediately let's say uses for
prediction it's well not the best way
because if you want to do it you want to
first like prune and quantize your
neural network
and also what we can do we can train on
completely unseen novel data sets
because this is actually what you see
in the live case scenarios um
the client says we have a lot of data
when you start inspecting this data
it seems not and it's really really hard
to do so the home assignments uh you can
play retrain
this model on a new data set please
share your results i'm really curious to
see it
i also only tried it for the
client data set that unfortunately is
not able to share its manufacturing data
set
um so with manufacturing data sets uh
it works even uh yeah worse
because there are not a lot of uh let's
say
not a lot of novel categories but
they're really specific one
so it still sometimes picks up really
random stuff
so i should say that if you look at
the classification
so it works okay it can identify that
this
present but when it comes to applying
mask
it can do some really weird stuff uh
then
also please go try out the metal
learning techniques
especially zero shot learning because
imagine if you have some
let's say text and based on this text or
if you have
images and based on the images you can
find something so it's really really
cool
also uh what you can trying to do you
can find a suitable model
like to be to build a basic meta search
app
um yeah let's say i want to input some
a description like person sitting
drinking coffee
and just look for the results or you can
ask let's say upload two or three images
and say
give me uh go for look for it and find
me this images
so yeah there's a lot of um
this is really interesting format for me
as well because normally all workshops
has a lot of
uh hands-on stuff in it so you can
follow along
uh you can stop you can ask questions
it's really weird to talk to the
uh to your computer sitting in your room
uh really and usually the workshops that
i gives like three hours or more with
more practical hands-on stuff
um but for me i say that this workshop
is
a little like literally for beginners um
just to understand how you can really
fast go from the research paper code and
just to try to build api around it and
to see what you can take from it so i
completely skip all parts about
how you can build how to improve all the
layers uh what it can do
um yeah and then
as a bonus uh i have a really nice
checklist for modeling deployment please
share it with your colleagues
i want to say that this uh two
checklists like modeling checklist and
deployment checklist
it was taken from the medium article of
this person there is a link to this
article as well
so uh here
we have like the basic stuff uh it will
take time to read it through
uh yeah i think that it's that's it
um yeah so
in this case i think if i was even was
too fast to finish it like 12 minutes
earlier so
now if you have any questions uh
please do oh the same mary's handball
accident okay
misclicked um so
feel free sorry once again it was a
little bit biased
and it was a little bit cumbersome
because i want to share
as much as possible in the really short
period of time but the goal was
just to show how it's um let's say
relatively easy to go from the
um research paper uh to find a way
some hacks around it to keep it to keep
it working
um this is the issue with a lot of
research papers they
really great great ideas with a really
cumbersome
uh code implementation um
yeah and usually uh from my own
experience
uh i i didn't mention i'll forget to
mention that
usually um so i i prefer
if it's possible to go without neural
networks
so because sometimes it can just solve
with easy things
um if it's about neural networks i have
hands-on
hands-on experience and production
experience only with computer vision
tasks so everything regarding llp is
still i'm still really curious there are
a lot of
um on the market that you can research
investigate like spacey
and all this stuff so it's really cool
so so far for me the computer vision
stuff
mostly for manufacturing companies uh
when you do
quality um quality tracking um
or when you try to understand or like um
records from
uh even from processing records from
security cameras um and to see what's
happening
on the planned level um on the fab
on the like industrial level what's
happening there
or such things like uh identify the
crops
um or like all the computer vision
related stuff
it's a really awesome field i think it's
a lot of
lots of things that can be improved as
well
and it's really hard to do stuff because
for us
for us as a person it's really easy and
actually if you look at us
as people uh you can always say
okay so we do actually the meta learning
so
if you see if you have seen something uh
two or three times
it's enough for you to understand that
okay this this is maybe it's a dog so it
doesn't matter what kind of
breed of the dog is you know that it's a
dog and you know it
but for the computer vision model it's
just a bunch of floats that's it
and the magic how you can go from floats
to let's say the real
uh classification let's say classifier
that will say okay this is this
particular
type of dog this is this or yeah so i
think the
there are a lot of possibilities and
opportunities um the field evolves a lot
as well so a lot of libraries pops up um
the the stuff still pythagoras
tensorflow
um is leading and yeah
and a lot of pre-processing libraries i
see some companies i see right now
building the
um like feature storages when you first
like
click the most useful features and uh in
order to save computational resources
you just don't
uh recompute it again and again and
again so it's really cool um really nice
really interesting uh
projects and yeah regarding the the
deployment red different options um and
as i mentioned before for example i
personally love to work with seldom
um if i run uh the the stuff in
kubernetes because actually we sell them
you get a yaml file where you specify
uh the whole deployments pipeline what
should be there like preprocessors all
the stuff
and then you do the magic you don't even
need to write any api so it's do it for
you
and it can do a b testing it can do
multi-arm bandits
so a lot of stuff is already
pre-packaged
also right now working on the machine
learning ops platform
that tried to cover um all the pipeline
from the data ingestion
uh taking an account data governance
data lineage that goes to the
all steps what's happening with data how
they were pre-processed
of course using ml flow on the
background to log
all parameters hyper parameters metrics
binary artifacts um and then to decide
what is the best option then
bring it to protection and then to see
immediately
like integrating with all necessary
stuffs with
icd pipelines so it's really wonderful
to see
what's happening so yeah
once again say thank you so much i see
those like eight minutes no questions
or it was really terrible that there is
no questions or it was too much in the
really short period of time
um we'll see anyway i think we can be
uh on discord after so i also curious to
see what's happened with this condo
environment as well
um oh i i see you want questions
yeah the good questions what happened to
visualization in your wrapper it was
very last night
uh what oh it was just transformed from
visualize airbnb
to the uh workshop slides it was just
merged that's what's the original idea
of it
um yeah
yeah that's that's actually what
happened i also want to investigate
right now what's happening with the
shapes for the
large config um okay
okay just use workshop um yeah yeah so
now it's like workshop slides instead
right
and once again it's only inference part
so if you want to
do some training if you want to retrain
this model uh
i have at the bottom of the readme file
i have the links to original repos
uh to see him is musk cnn to the masker
cnn
so just go there and check it
and it has dif so you can actually you
can do transfer learning on different
levels um you can start it's just from
the backbone from
resnet uh they have the three option
three weights
for the different uh imagenet datasets
without the interference with ms cocoset
category
or you can retrain it from for example
from the middle
uh from what i see now the small
configuration has
160 um books with
uh 1000 images in each uh
then the big one was like 320.
and and actually how they train so first
they train the heads
then they go to the let's say middle
layers you train the middle layers and
at the end you have the
um they actually decrease the learning
rates uh
to not decrease they actually uh
how you say it's not split okay so you
you make your learning rate 10 10 times
slower
and so for now for especially for novel
categories
um because of this a little bit
overfitting on the mask cocoa because of
some of the categories that pops up
really
like people that are all over the place
all the cluttered images
uh then for some something it can
perform so well for some knots so there
are different options what to do with it
um yeah and also take into account if
you want to play with cmu's mask or cnn
they have a little bit changed masker
synonym source code in it
so if you want just to play with mark um
air cnn go to their
repo if you want to play with play with
siamese mask or cnn
then just follow the same miss masker
cnn repo
and as i mentioned before for people who
use windows
unfortunately there are a lot of
hardcoded stuff in this source code
and the path i represent in the standard
unix format so
yeah you need to actually dig into it or
just
install vsl and run ubuntu windows
that's what i'm doing right now for this
presentation
and it will helps you yeah
i think that's it uh yeah and the
goal yeah sorry thank you very much
it was uh so i'm not someone who does a
lot of computer vision and i
so so i find it very very inspiring very
fun to see like what's possible and what
you can do with it
yeah but what i i want to say that like
for all people like no mates so
he is a person he's standing behind the
secret lego library
so i think it's together with winston
right so you can just like it's all
about open source it's all about
there are what we are giving back to the
community so please go check
and uh tomorrow we'll have this open
like the panda sprints
but as i assume you can actually create
the pull request and fix basic bugs or
write documentation so that's
what i want to say so if you're a
beginner if you have never
have any experience doing something for
open source start small
start with basic tasks or documentation
that's let's say low hanging fruits
and then you can if you feel that you
can do something more
then do it or for example if you're
working on the project and there is a
pass and you reusing some open source
components you can always get
give back for now for example for the
last project i used to work with fba
profit it was
really cumbersome experience the first
time in my life when i came across
the the model that takes data frame as
an input and returns data frame as
output
so everything regarding using spark it's
really terrible because you need to
transfer to
um user-defined pandas data frames
and the whole process so all games that
you can
can get from the let's say fast spark
processing it will be just killed
by this model to work with your data so
the whole model it doesn't work in a
distributed manner
so and for this fb profits uh while
working with ml flow and while working
with azure so there are a lot of things
that are not compatible so in this case
if the customer allows me i can always
reuse this code and
just give it back to the community with
some improvements for fb profit
or some improvements for male flow so
there are a lot of stuff
happening around so please do and once
again
don't forget this awesome library maybe
it's like it's like two minutes left
maybe mates can share a little bit about
this library because it's awesome uh
yeah so for everyone who uses psychic
learn you probably
had at some point ran into something
that you
missed inside could learn um that also
happened to me that also happened to
vincent that happened to a bunch of our
colleagues and people we know
and at some point we decided well let's
just put them all together
and make a pip installable um so that
means there's like
there's some models in there that take
different losses into account
there's some models in there that try to
stay
they try to remain fair with regards to
some kind of protected attributes
there's cross validators there's a ton
of
meta meta estimators that do
stuff like sampling or fitting a model
per group and trying to re-weigh those
in in interesting ways
um it's not really an overarching theme
except for
things that are useful when you use
scikit-learn
we're very open to contributors we've
had many people just pop up out of
nowhere and
say hey i think this could be a cool
addition or
actually you you build something that's
broken can i fix it
and we always love those if you do make
a pull request
i have a huge stack of stickers here
somewhere
the logo is pretty good as you can see
so um give me um give me a message and
i'll send you a sticker
yeah it's really great one and i just
like pop it here
so yeah it's here it's sick lego and
it's awesome
especially take a look as well on the
pandas pipelines
because what i notice a lot of people
have no clue that it exists and it's
really cool concept
and it's really help you to clean up
your code as well
and to see what's happening in the whole
pipeline how it runs but sorry maybe i'm
just biased once again tourist machine
learning engineering
that's why i'm thinking about it kind of
pipelines are probably my favorite part
and i'm still salty that
the same thing doesn't work as well as
spark
yeah i think i think the transformer
method was released in in spark 3 but
it it doesn't take keyword arguments or
q or does the car aren't
quarks it's not the same but
yeah cool okay
so i see that yeah it's time to conclude
our session
so for people please ask your questions
please
be as critical as possible and talk to
me on discord i will be here
with you for one next next hour just to
keep it working
to keep it flowing thank you so much
thank you all so much
and thank you all for attending as well
hope to see you either in the lunch
session or the talks later today again
great and thanks again now leona yeah
thanks
bye